thank you um i'm i'm fiddling around
here because I want to make sure I can
see my notes even though remarks as a
remarkably open term and it means I can
really say anything like to make sure I
have my notes and I do but some people
call me a recovered archivist but you
can really never recover from the
pleasure of working with educational
media which was a large chunk of what I
used to collect and so I'm going to
begin with a lightning-fast skim over
the surface of the history of moving
images in education film goes back about
a hundred thirteen years but visual ed
goes even further back perhaps beginning
with comedians touted to be one of the
first visual educators this is from an
1842 edition of his Orbis pictus come
here boy learn to be wise this is the
Orbis itself on the Orbis pictus is
interesting it depicts its world and
many of its imperfections I've omitted
the pictures that go with this little
passage but at the same time some
interesting rather utopian things were
happening 1826 the Lyceum movement
founded in Massachusetts that should
talk when 1874 adult education
face-to-face learning traveling around
the country and before that are at the
same time the panorama the museum the
cabinet of curiosities now undergoing
renaissance lantern slides of course um
the term visual education goes back to
1906 we think and this is edison making
his first predictions fortunately or
unfortunately he got it wrong you see
that in 1913 he was suggesting that
essentially by 1923 that books would be
dead and he tried to cover his tracks in
1922 it's a little unfair to pick on
Edison but this is canonical so here you
go visual educators were the educational
radicals of their day and I'd love to
fort down this point when we get to
bureaucratic they believed in the truth
the efficacy and the efficiency of the
image their journals and text books are
filled with almost obligatory critiques
of verbal ism
of course today trying to fight verbal
ism in this talk to their there even
when it came to advocating felt boards
and field trips over text books and rote
learning visual leathers are very very
broad umbrella they kept constantly
updated totals of the numbers of films
that were sitting in school film
libraries the deployment of projectors
and schools it's almost like now you
hear all the figures on broadband
penetration and so on they fought for
two things really to build a
distribution infrastructure and then to
populate it with what we would today
call content ugh audio-visual educators
were not just they didn't confine their
activism to on schools per se they
actively promoted AV and further
education and perhaps most interestingly
in the community I'm thinking of the
film council movement this was a social
movement as well it was led by a
decentralized network of optimists
throughout the country in the world oops
who believe that no community should be
left behind in AV revolution they
organize screenings and topics on on
discussions on burning importance
they're still actually a few film counts
as left including one in New York in the
history we've we know the general
outlines 1921 Yale tries the really for
almost the first time to systematically
cover one subject in the curriculum with
the chronicles of America series which
actually are still sitting in many film
libraries even
they're 80 years old starting in the
late 20s the development of Eastman
teaching films then the first
peer-reviewed tests on the efficacy of
classroom film and then later on a
spin-off to her p and britannica World
War 2 the big the big sort of watershed
brought us the a-bomb radar thousands
upon thousands of surplus 16 millimeter
projectors hundreds of new educational
media producers including the mom and
pop shops his work is sometimes quite
unusual the Cold War in the National
Defense Education Act of nineteen
fifty-eight birth to a rich corpus of
films and filmmakers some say this is
one it all went downhill when well that
he suffered because there was too much
money coming into the field the birth of
educational TV 1948 and three cities
initially is a classroom media and
on-site and then over the air 1952 any T
programs start to exchange instructional
TV gets big in the late 50s and early
60s and people are very they have a
great sense of its promise the Ford
Foundation spends 25 million to study
ITV schools are overcrowded there's the
baby boom there's a school funding
crisis there's a teacher shortage and in
the most general terms the idea was to
put talented teachers on TV and then
have ordinary classroom teachers be the
supplementation do individual
instruction this was not a success and
then the 60s this is another interesting
point if you're interested in kind of
media ecology and how its reflected in
style we see educational film detour
into an endless loop of super 8
cartridges which were hailed for at
times the future of visual education
where no lesson can exceed 10 minutes we
see a progression of early video formats
this is what make archivists tear their
hair out today and above all we see an
anti hierarchical movement and an end to
certain kinds of authority the old films
how do I do this the old films where
every image was carefully composed where
you never saw anything
scroll um the old films which every
image was very carefully composed you
never saw anything by accident they gave
way to sort of visually chaotic
unpredictable day-in-the-life films that
were heavily influenced by cinema verite
by the New Wave often with 20 guitar
soundtracks production shifted from
places like Chicago and Hollywood to
Cambridge and Berkeley at the same time
you see the beginning of diversity of
faces in the films and subjects that are
being treated this by the way is the old
woman TV station in Chicago during world
war two did you know about that I've
always wanted to make a documentary
about how the world changed between 1950
and 2000 and use educational films to
tell the story how educational films
shouldered the responsibility for
changing consciousness promoting
self-esteem values clarification moved
away from learning to more to softer but
in some ways just as profound if not
more subjects the emergence from the
margins of women and so-called
minorities how change was reflected in
style and how the film's document this
that's my six hour PBS program pitch um
there's also a parallel narrative which
is how not theatrical film which was
once an artisanal activity turned into a
highly organized and differentiated
industry and now it's gone back to being
a special practice a high art and we
film people don't like that so to sum up
University productions very very long
tradition back to the teens frankly etv
another long tradition 1948 on moved
from the lecture and morphed into public
TV today and rather than bringing the
classroom out into the world or brings
the world into the classroom there's
been a shift on a large large
educational film industry many may a few
majors and then this large cadre of
homegrown mom-and-pop filmmakers
in-house production boom courseware then
the interactive tradition we're starting
to get closer to the present
teaching machines the films with
withwith sequences of black leader to
allow for you know classroom discussion
participation what would you do what do
you think then video disc so all in all
perhaps of a quarter of a million works
produced in an uncountable number of
educational TV programs just a handful
are still a distribution or even
remembered today and it's one of the
great great losses of media history the
most much of this work turned out to be
ephemeral um so a few thoughts about
possible best practices I have four in
no particular order leverage existing
resources so there's vaults which today
we're starting to call silos full of
existing works that no one might ever
get to see let alone reuse we're being
excessively deferential in the face of
claims we haven't received from
copyright holders we can identify we
need to free educational media from
obscurity much of it at first glance
might seem to have no current value this
rule of the five percent or some people
say the ten percent sand people say the
one percent nobody knows um but if you
fix the material in a longer days there
is it there there and many of these
programs i think have value of segments
if not in their original form um i think
we need to free educational and public
television archives and we need to break
up the stasis my cult funders today is
let's may we convene and figure out how
to organize the great by out of all the
rights that are bundled with in
educational and public TV from year one
to today my nine is 33 years ago and do
it at a bulk discount rate could we try
to dimana ties what's a relatively
economically and significant but
tremendously important area of culture
and make it freely available this is
something we'll come back to
segmentation granularity this may seem a
small topic and unworthy of Aquino but I
actually think it's
small thing that yields large benefits
on we can add substantial value to the
archival heritage or the archival corpus
by cutting it into little pieces as the
architect Keller Easterling once said
subtraction is growth and it's just as
true for film and video as it is for
urban planning I'll explain at the
Internet Archive there's almost 2,000
films through my archives up each
averaging about 12 minutes in length
it's really hard to touch a 12-minute
rich media object they're not internally
addressable you can't tell the site to
start playing offset three minutes 10
seconds from the head you can't tell the
site to concatenate one segment with
another and build a playlist and our
archives are filled with quarter hour
half hour hour-long shows and I I know
that there will be tools and you know
some sites support this already where
you can offset where you can go and but
in some ways if we break them into short
logical segments with human intervention
I'm not talking about doing this
automatically here we actually gained a
tremendous amount of value and I think
we can add coherence to the sprawling
unwieldy body of legacy media
collections I like the fact that queries
might respond more closely two hits I
love the fact that you could support
informal browsing have to move away from
the situation where queries are sort of
do or die so we might do this with our
film that we give away for free and it's
something you could actually charge for
as an added value service openness the
concept of open production which this is
all about which peter is articulated
which Hewlett many of the other people
here it's tremendously exciting it's
these production not as a one-shot deal
but as a continuum and it recognizes
that openness and education have are
conceptually and practically tied
together but if we want to avoid doing
educational TV in public to me all over
again we need to do some hard work with
the
welcome this openness is not binary and
content terrible word isn't simply open
or closed open this we need to think of
as a broad spectrum of possible
interactions between educators producers
archives and users openness is tough on
what does it mean here's an example open
this means not just seeing the image of
a book page but seeing the text too and
be able to mix and manipulate it this is
one of the books we've scanned in
partnership with the internet or kind of
there's the page image on the left this
is typically what you'd see it's a PDF
Google will show you a PDF Microsoft
will show you a PDF there's the ASCII
text dirty as it comes out of the
software but you can take that text and
you can mash it up you can quote it you
can paste it into your own document it's
open its open or content so we're not
just talking about watching a movie but
being free to download the shots the edl
the timeline make your own cut this is
very BBC creative archive and I really
have to follow what Paul said by talking
about how important the creative archive
has been it's been the focus of many
many people's hopes so many people who
are out there lay people not
professional media producers have been
watching the creative archive and it's
raised expectations tremendously and I
hope we can support him and I I also
hope that if it can't be done at the BBC
let's do it here it's really really
important so not just a movie but the
the components not just the music but
the MIDI open us on the web means that
everyone could crawl navigate and index
what they find an openness isn't simply
the freedom to to consume to read listen
watch feel smell taste on thinking about
web something point 0 but also the
freedom to remix in these same domains
so in the digital world that means you
really have to get your hands on the
object itself and touch the code that
makes it player display and everything
needs to be editable and I'd also add
that openness means freedom to Anna
take freedom to share the network
experience with others and in order to
make that happen we'll really need to
integrate editing tools better with our
services we talk at the Internet Archive
a lot about the Swiss Army knife for
video that allows you to do primitive
concatenation primitive playlists no no
fancy you know you don't need the you
don't need the blur filter whatever but
you just need to be able to make some
playlists and pass them around openness
also enables interoperability and I
think this is something that people are
starting to think about in the in the
library world a great deal but think of
quilting quilting is a very early form
of sampling a patchwork quilt combines
pre-existing fabric from a variety of
sources and quilting relies on what
geeks go interoperability the ability of
elements to fit into a matrix and
functions together which is of course
what makes the internet work we have a
golden opportunity now to enable
interoperable systems services and
collections and I really hope we think
about that I'd like a piece of a program
from GBH online to fit in a playlist and
add it with something from Columbia from
the internet archive and even from from
google youtube interoperability rests on
openness and today openness is
threatened in many ways while some
companies that build business models
around openness there are many others
that have not and many nonprofit and
publicly funded organizations are
deferring to enclosure and sometimes
perpetuating it so that if we're to
freely cite the work of others and to
merge past and present and build these
new kinds of services and a new works
that we want to see we need to make sure
that openness is at the core of our
activities we need to default to
openness rather than the alternative so
that we can share cultural material as
freely as the law allows one less
thought on openness online video
archives are tremendous data sets for
computational research we don't see
enough of this in the open world a lot
of this happens in the in the in the
world
that's that's not publicly disclosed but
open video data sets are few and far
between and they're very much sought
after and these are other reasons why we
should should build this on moratorium
so six years ago I couldn't have
explained how we could put up our best
material online for free downloading and
unrestricted reuse and cause our revenue
to more than double I had no way to
imagine that there were no models to
follow we need new models we need to
give them the freedom to flourish and
I'm i would suggest one possibility is
that we declare a period of
experimentation for educational video
we're almost anything can go in other
words to declare a moratorium I
understand that it has to be temporary
on enclosure on complex licensing
arrangements on restrictive copyrights
let's make a period where new models can
define themselves and flourish let's um
let's enable Paris in the 20s rather
than silicon valley in the 90s that's
another way of putting it on let some
different Ecology's fleurs see what
sticks see which ones can cause the
production of better media for at least
a few years let's supply copyright
homeopathic alee rather than a weapon of
shock and awe I don't know if we can do
this but the more territory that we
claim in the more models we can float
the stronger this field will be and then
if we decide that we're going to be
about billable events and some of us
will have to be about billable events
there'll be many more ways to make them
happen so really really quickly a few
points of departure to put my recovered
archivists hat back on it's very very
happy to be here one of the cool things
about this project is that wicked with
the opportunity to bridge production
archiving and education archives really
really need this and here's why moving
image archives face a very complex set
of pressures right now traditionally the
privileged preservation over access you
know we're talking about best-of-breed
today that was not best-of-breed
although he was much loved in part if
this has been because of deference to
copyright holders and in part because of
a legacy culture that's made access a
very sticky door as we were just talking
about but in recent years archives have
faced unprecedented demand for their
holdings from a completely new group of
users archives have gone retail people
look upon archives as the dog looks upon
the plate of cookies it's the
unattainable gold that they want but
they can't get and some forward-thinking
collections have tried to respond to
this and figure it out how to open up to
the public and go online but we run into
problems and there's the YouTube issue
this is a little mini rant about youtube
and i would i'd summarize it this way
media archives face such internal
opposition and such difficulty from
copyright holders that they tend to take
baby steps towards opening up their
collections and then suddenly amid all
of these good intentions we have YouTube
which in a very short time raised public
expectations which is a wonderful
wonderful thing but they raise public
expectations to the point that it's hard
to see how any public institution can
ever meet them you know we can't do what
YouTube does we don't have the latitude
so I don't want to overdramatize but I
think archives lost and we have to
figure out how to recoup um so education
is the strategic direction it may keep
moving image archives and their chips
over the next few years a closer
relationship to the education sectors
may be just what archives need to renew
and sustain the consensus that
legitimizes them keeps a little bit of
funding flowing you know archives really
rest on what I believe is ultimately a
fairly tenuous social and cultural
consensus there has to be a sailor it's
worth supporting them and if people
begin to look at archives as
institutions that are obstacles to
access archives they're in trouble and
you know there's a generational shift
about how people regard archives so we
really have to to push lack of archives
will kill that culture
consensus we can learn from England
where they're doing break things the UK
lives under a rights regime that we
would Americans would consider draconian
you have much less than a public domain
there's many more people that owned a
chunk of media and yet despite these
limitations it's this perfect example
you know that you can put limitations in
some ways allow you to to prosper on
they're doing so much more than we are
to mobilize archives and make them
available as long as you work within the
education sectors in England you can do
tremendous tremendous things so it isn't
the populist paradise but it's a good
start we've heard from Murray that the
BFI is putting feature films another
wonderful material online through the
media tech and screen online and they've
started working on voices which is a
landmark project to put all sorts of
really really interesting material about
the evolution of policy society and
culture online we need to emulate these
projects and in doing so will liberate
archives from our legacy history um we
always think a lot about repurposing
because the archives are fallen
sometimes people think it's cheaper to
repurpose material than to make new
content on this should give us pause
there's a long history of this on MGM
cut its features into short educational
films which they distribute it you know
gangster films became cut down they went
into the crime does not pay series
actually kind of almost a the reversal
of the original you know exploitation
intent um this has been you know we have
many many TV shows and they can we could
do this with but I wonder about
reconstituting material that's basically
entertainment as education and a lot of
material that's been pushed through
educational and public TV channels of
distribution in the past few years is
probably somewhat more entertainment i
buy it's going to take some thought
about repurposing should we digitize all
the lectures you know should we should
all course where it be uh
are we really doing the muder museum all
over again you know the Medical Museum
in Philadelphia it's a 19th century
Victorian cabinet of medical curiosities
and it turns out not to be so much about
medicine as it is about medical museums
so it's self referential and I wonder if
old educational programs are really
about old educational programs um so do
we need to break with the past this is a
Socratic question or alternatively is
everything just raw material for future
mashups and I'd say let's leave this to
the viewers and the students to resolve
the idea that we turn viewers into
makers and consumers into producers it's
gotten a lot of play and it's getting a
little old but it's still a practical
way of striving towards utopia um
user-generated content in rich's the
libraries but it also embodies a
dialogue between educators and producers
and audiences and I'd say that this
dialogue isn't just going to be about
the substance of the resources what's in
them but about their shape and design
and one thing is clear we're going to
have to come to terms with the language
and not just the style of gaming so
these are some of my thoughts and thank